we've already taken a good look at
Europe during World War two and a lot of
y'all might have been saying okay it
involved most of the countries in Europe
what was going on in Spain Spain's
obviously a significant country in
Europe and the simple answer is is that
by the outbreak of the official outbreak
of world war ii in 1939 a spain was in
no position to participate in any
significant way because it had just
emerged from its own extremely bloody
civil war so you have from nineteen let
me write this in a color you have from
1936 to 1939
you had the Spanish Civil War spanish
civil Spanish Civil War and the Spanish
Civil War was at its essence a conflict
between the left and the right the Left
represented by the Republicans
Republicans and the right represented by
the Nationalists by the Nationalists and
if you want to get a very high-level
sense of what they each represented the
Republicans were actually the
democratically elected government Spain
was established as a republic in 19 or
for the second time became a republic in
1931 and it had and it had elections and
in the 1936 elections the leftist
Popular Front comes to power and it
wasn't you know all of this doesn't just
happen all of a sudden in the run-up to
the the 1936 elections through the 30s
you have this constant tension this
escalating tension this escalating
polarization between left and right and
just to get a sense a very high-level
sense of what some what they represented
the word Republican in its in its most
general form really means or public
refers to any form of government in
which you do not have a monarchy in
control it could be a full
representational democracy in which
there is broad power spread amongst the
people or it could be something in
between or maybe a smaller subset of
people have power or it's more of a of
an indirect democracy or whatever you
want to say it but
Republic is anything that does not
involve direct control by a monarchy and
if you think about the leftist Popular
Front the leftist Popular Front it was
sympathetic to the ideas coming out of
the Soviet Union sympathetic to the
ideas of of communism
it was quite anti religion in particular
or was kind of anti the the traditional
institutions both the monarchy and the
Church Spain was and is a Catholic
country and so it was not it was not
friendly to the Catholic Church and on
the other side you have the Nationalists
and the Nationalists I guess you could
say are the opposite they're vehemently
anti-communist they are pro monarchy
they are pro a Catholic Church or at
least in Spain they're pro Catholic
Church they have ideas of kind of a
Bolshevik a communist Jewish Masonic
conspiracy so you can imagine these had
all these folks right over here had a
lot in common with Hitler and the Nazis
and and also fascist Italy and the
Nationalists included fascist elements
some historians will also refer to the
Nationalists as fascists although
there's some dispute about how fascist
they were where they were they were
whether they were officially fascist or
whatever else but they had a lot in
common lot in common with fascist Italy
fascist Italy fascist Italy under
Mussolini and and Nazi Germany under
Adolf Hitler so Nazi Nazi Germany and
not only did they have a lot of Phylis
kind of philosophical alignment with the
the ultra-nationalists in Germany and in
Italy they were supported by the the by
Hitler's regime and they were supported
by Mussolini
on the nationalist side so you have this
outbreak of civil war where you have the
democratically elected leftist Popular
Front the Nationalists don't like it
they're initially under the control of
this gentleman right over here Jose San
horville I'm
good with pronunciations but he died
shortly after the the the rebellion the
civil war begins and it's he kind of
dies in a fairly ironic way his plane
crashes because it was carrying too much
luggage it was carrying his luggage and
he was even warned before getting on the
plane that hey I don't know if it's a
good idea for you to carry all of this
luggage and his his reply or at least
what I've been able to fight flying what
history has recorded is his reply is I
need to wear proper clothes as the new
Cod do of Spain and the term Cod do is
is kind of like I'm going to be the
strong man or the ruler of Spain and
it's it's analogous to the word Fuhrer
in German or duche in Italian so you
know this guy's saying oh you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna take control of this
country I need to wear proper clothes
those clothes cause his plane to to
crash and so he once he's gone the
leader of the nationalist front becomes
Francisco Francisco Franco and Francisco
Franco and I encourage you to read more
and this is a you know an overview video
of his life he he is able to lead the
Nationalists to a victory in the Spanish
Civil War but it is an extremely
extremely bloody civil war estimates are
that between two hundred and five
hundred thousand people were killed in
Spain during the Spanish Civil War and
just to have some perspective this is in
a country that at the time had a
population of about 25 million people so
we have 500 thousand that's what one
fiftieth of the population died this
isn't even talking about people who are
imprisoned people who are had to leave
their homes people who might have been
refugees people who might have who might
have been casualties in other way so an
extremely extremely a bloody civil war
and if you really want to get a a
tangible sense for what frankly what war
is like but specifically what the
Spanish Civil War was like I encourage
you to read for Whom the Bell Tolls by
Ernest Hemingway and Ernest Hemingway
actually was a reporter in Spain during
the Spanish Civil War so we took to a
large degree he had he had firsthand
observations of the Spanish Civil War
this book is not is not autobiographical
although it's based on
his experiences but it's actually it's
it's you know it's one of the books that
I've read that really at least in my
brain gave me a richer picture of how of
how horrible war could be or at least
certain aspects of war and it takes
place in the mountains a little bit a
little bit north a little bit north of
Madrid and just to have kind of a little
bit more cultural context you know that
this was this was a painting that
Salvador Dali created in 1936 as he saw
this imminent civil war emerging and you
know like many Salvador Dali paintings
it was a quite it's quite trippy is is
the best where it's kind of this
distorted human being it was called soft
construction with boiled beans and then
in parentheses premonition of a civil
war so this had this had wide-ranging
cultural impacts many of which we we
even kind of appreciate today with works
like For Whom the Bell Tolls and Dolly's
paintings but Francisco Franco he's able
to take control of Spain the war ends in
1939 once again he was aligned with the
Nazis he was aligned with the fascists
but by the time World War two breaks out
in 1939 Spain's in shambles he's in no
position to to in any significant way
aid aid the Axis powers and frankly the
first few years of his regime he's just
consist continuing to consolidate power
in a fairly brutal way the in the first
five years the fewest number of
executions that occurred in Spain was
50,000 executions per year and this is
in a population of once again at this
point in roughly 25 million and
Francisco power of Francisco Franco is
able to remain in power for a long time
all the way through 1975 and and at
first you can imagine because he was
aligned with Italy in Germany the Allies
weren't weren't enthusiastic about about
his regime Spain was not a founding
member of the UN but as soon as the Cold
War started to go in in in more full
fashion after World War Two you have
this guy who is
who is super anti-communist you could
imagine that that the United States and
and the West you know they kind of held
their noses a little bit and said all
right well we didn't like this guy
during during World War two and we don't
agree with a lot of a lot of how he runs
his country but hey he's anti-communist
and we're trying to get together
everyone who's anti-communist and so he
was able to the West did bring them a
little bit more into alignment and they
were able to become part of NATO and and
and the the kind of national Spain
Francisco Franco's regime really didn't
start to end until his death in 1975 at
which at which Juan Carlos became king
again
but then he helped Shepherd the
transition to a full democracy in Spain
you have the constitution of 1978 so
anyway you know big picture just so you
have a sense of what was going on in
other parts of Europe during World War
two
just as Hitler was was militarizing
and/or really militarizing and at the
end of the nineteen thirties preparing
for his his aggressive actions you had
this extremely extremely bloody a civil
war in Spain that that put in power of
Francisco Franco for a long for a long
for a long time to come